well hello my name is Steven Ferguson
and I'm a scientist in the national
toxicology program at the National
Institute of Environmental Health
Sciences and today I'm going to speak to
you about some of our efforts in
development of new approach missus
methods for toxicology research and the
title of my presentation is the power of
resolution context and physiological
relevance to model hepatic responses to
xenobiotic exposures and as a federal
employee I must remind everyone that I
have no financial relationships to
disclose in the statements and opinions
and conclusions that I make are my own
and do not necessarily reflect those of
the NIH s ni H or the US government so
many of you may be familiar with the the
talks 21 program I'm part of that
program and the program's been going on
since 2005 to to work towards using
innovative strategies in toxicology
research they help us better understand
molecular pathways that are being
interacted and with with environmental
and and other reference chemicals and
that program has been going on for some
time now and while it's had great
success in many many ways one of the
biggest challenges that has been raised
with the program is the lack of
xenobiotic metabolism we know in the
field of toxicology that metabolism is
an essential process for many compounds
in terms of detoxification and metabolic
activation and so the the vast majority
of the the new approach methods that
have been used in phase one and two of
talks 21 and related areas have been
devoid or very limited in that and
presumed to be limited in that they also
the the pathways that are covered have
been limited to what was commercially
available or what had been developed in
academic labs focusing on individual
pathways rather than necessarily
integrating those pathways in a more
physiological context towards
progressions of toxicological response
that might manifest an apical outcomes
and in toxicology and then also most of
the assays were addition only assays
with minimal
the ability to look at longitudinal or
through time studies to understand the
progression of responses and so one of
the things when I came into the program
was to try to say well where are we in
terms of you know body metabolism and I
come from an area that's focused on
using liver cells derived from human
liver to predict drug metabolism and
drug drug interaction potential and when
you look at the metabolic activity in
suspensions of primary human of pata
sites derive from the liver what's are
shown in the very tall bars on the far
left of the bar graph you can see the
metabolic activities in this case
specific activities for clinically
relevant substrates fine a certain
bupropion and midazolam far exceed those
that we saw in the the legacy tox 21
assays down in the end of low regions
and even though you might use more
physiologically relevant cell types such
as primary pata sites or hep RG cells in
culture over 48 to 72 hours they fall
well short of this bar and so our goal
in the program is attempt to confer Xena
body metabolism now the challenge is tox
21 is largely used immortal or cancer
cell lines such as Hep C 2 cells that do
have some limited and skewed capacity to
metabolize things but when you look at
the structure of the human liver you see
that it's a complex structure and and
that the complexities and the dynamics
that are going on in these tissues are
far exceed the complexity and modeling
of cells that are that are cancer cells
that are sticking on plastic and heavily
proliferating because that proliferation
can impact their ability to model
metabolic competence and so the most
successful models have been those that
are derived directly from human liver as
you see on the upper left and the cells
in suspension form directly isolated or
those that have been cultured to try to
model more chronic responses have been
successfully used to predict
quantitatively metabolic clearance
metabolic or uptake clearance in the
liver as well as liver enzyme induction
and inhibition and transport
including biliary transport to be able
to integrate data from these in vitro
systems into pharmacokinetics models
that enable us to estimate and in some
cases predict the potential for drug
drug interactions and and drug clearance
rates and and mechanisms and in many
cases those data are used for
decision-making to decide whether
clinical trials are necessary or simply
the in vitro data can be used for drug
labeling so these these become an
opportunity to leverage this kind of
approach in the tox 21 program but it's
important to understand that when the
primary pata sites are ripped out of the
native context of the human liver they
begin to rapidly D differentiate and the
metabolic confidence that's so strong in
these suspension cells only has a
half-life of one and a half to three
hours for major
clearance enzymes if the cells are
simply maintained in a suspension at 37
degrees but if the cells are cultured
they actually can retain the metabolic
competence that they expressed in vivo
for roughly 24 hours and you see this
little window of time where the
half-life is actually extended for these
enzymes about 10 fold and so now you
have a half-life of about 20 to 30 hours
and that's an opportunity but it's still
the system begins to D differentiate as
it adapts to this new cell culture
environment and it's still limiting for
us to be able to model metabolic
activity when we're only achieving about
10 percent of the metabolic confidence
that we had in the the liver and so the
tox 21 program is really bringing online
these models as well as other models
that get closer to the bar of metabolic
competence and integrating improved
cellular differentiation and
functionality models ones that confer
metabolic competence for both
detoxification and metabolic activation
they have superior longevity so for
example primary rata pata sites and 2d
culture might last for 3 to 5 days and a
standard sandwich culture configuration
whereas in 3d models and and flow models
you've seen cells that can last for four
weeks weeks on end and in our lab we've
actually done it even
I'll show you some examples and then
ultimately for our program we're trying
to build relationships between our rich
legacy and vivo data to understand what
the cross species parallelogram looks
like when we try to relate human and
vitro to Rodin in vitro
Roatan in vitro to rodent in vivo and
then build that context out with
pharmaceuticals and and and other
compounds that are consumed by humans
out to understand the clinical or the
human environmental exposure that we can
ultimately build those relationships
that build confidence in the new
approach methods but it's important that
any of these methods be able to model
the biological response that includes
for the liver of metabolic activation to
better mimic the exposures that are
produced internally in in vivo so in
addition to that we want to bring online
multiple multi dimensional assay
platforms so you have a model systems
that's modeling the complexities of all
this these processes but you want to be
able to bring online various
technologies to let you image what's
happening to let you understand the
genomics or the molecular level changes
that are happening in an adaptive way as
well as metabolomics where things are
actually changing and we can begin to
relate the changes that are happening in
these various molecular pathways to
broader context of understanding cause
and effect relationships and it's
critical that in these approaches we
leverage the power of resolution that's
offered with higher throughput systems
so that we can monitor the time and
concentration progressions that happen
in these systems ultimately in order for
any of these new approach methods to be
successful they have to have
quantitative translation to humans and
so building bridges to internal exposure
concentrations see steady-state c-max
with in vitro potencies and having a
common calibrated method for scaling
that as well as extrapolating that out
to the external dose is key and then
ultimately as we gain confidence in a
model system is able to predict
a single person's response we then
expand that out to populations and
disease states as well as other other
culture models like kidney and intestine
are two of the ones that were we're
focused on in the near future so for our
program we've actually focused
predominantly on primary human dupatta
sites and this cell line called HEPA RG
cells so it's important that when you
put these cells in these more complex
systems that they able to differentiate
and recover some of the invivo light
characteristics that they had and these
cells are particularly interesting
because they derive from a patient who
had a pile of cellular carcinoma
although they're not clonal and also had
hepatitis C the cells are negative for
hepatitis C but what happens with these
cells when they're put in culture for
about four weeks under a differentiation
protocol somewhat like stem cell
differentiation they will actually ride
along the the stem cell differentiation
tree and produce co-cultures of a pata
site like cells and Qalandia a lotta
site less cells as you can see and in
the upper middle figure here and that's
showing you staining with a CD FDA
staining so this is a particular
molecule that highlights the bile
canaliculi domains that form when these
a pata sites form nice epithelial layers
and they'll begin to polarize and form
bile ducts essentially bile bile
pathways these are bile canaliculi but
they're starting to to increase levels
of bile salts and bile acids and they
form these bile pockets in response to
that and you can actually stain for this
as evidence that the cells are
polarizing and beginning to model more
mature liver function and you see those
analogous structures are also produced
in human apat asides but the cells have
these hip Rajee cells have effective
transporter expression and function as
you saw in this figure the drug
metabolism activities mimic the ranges
that you see across hundreds of donor
preparations of human apat asides and
most importantly they're really the only
cell line that's been published to date
that are able to support
or car translocation so car is a
constitutive antigen receptor and it's
translocation of a car from the cytosol
to the nucleus in response to
phenobarbital is a hallmark of a
parasite functionality and so these data
show that it works and that the
induction fold data you see in the
bottom panel are analogous to what you
see in human liver now what we like most
about the cell type is it's our first
sort of tier and it has year-over-year
availability in the same donor
background so many of the challenges
with primary human dupatta sites are
there's a finite number of cells and
when a donor preparations supply of
cells is reached its end you really
can't do any more experiments in that
background so we like the idea of these
hip Rajee cells for that they also have
reduced variability and they're much
easier to work with in primary parasites
they're somewhat less expensive and they
also have a unique ability to adapt and
trans differentiate and so if you call
some type of injury or damage there
they're more likely as stem cell type
cells to be able to repair those those
areas and and and you can see the the
schematic here that was published in
Nature Reviews that basically just shows
you the the highway of stem cells
differentiation that these hip rgr
riding along going from progenitor cells
down to had a blast and hepatocyte sand
claim just that's what's thought to be
the case although it's still much work
to be done in this area now in our lab
when we started figuring out which
systems we were going to look at it was
important for us to have a screening
model something that we could run 3d for
wallplate assays to get the throughput
we needed to interrogate time and
concentration effects across sets of
chemicals roughly 10 to 100 chemical
range numbers of chemicals and we tried
different systems and there are lots of
systems of available available the
system we ended up settling on and the
initial publications were these Corning
ultra low affinity microplates you see
in the in the middle of the screen and
the very first plate that we ever tried
produced very nice farad's
and this is actually the image from that
very first plate and it worked perfectly
every will produces fear we were able to
feed the median chains of cells with a
via flow 3d for liquid handler and we
extended that work out into 3d for wall
plays what's really nice about the
system is it uses far fewer hepatocyte
sand so we see primary pad sites and
hippo G is a is a gift to the research
community to be able to study liver
function and it's basically a tenfold
more efficient use of cells if you can
get the endpoints that you're looking
for and so instead of one vial leading
to one 96-well plate now you can get ten
to a fifty to a hundred plates in 3d
using these configurations and in the 3d
you can get roughly twelve to twenty
five plates as you see here but this is
a work that was led in the lab by
Srinivasa Rama Hari
very talented postdoctoral fellow who's
now actually been promoted Research
Fellow within our program
and it made the cover of tox I you can
see across the plate nice consistency
across the plate and in the lower right
hand panel you see that the size metrics
just confirming the micron sizes of each
of the spheres across the plates and so
we're confident that we're able to
reproduce this consistently when we did
a monistic chemistry staining in
collaboration with Darlene Dixon a
molecular pathologist in our in our
branch we were able to see H&E staining
that was consistent with good quality
hepatocytes that are forming nice cell
so interactions glycogen staining was
confirmed by past staining so that the
spheres are able to store glycogen poly
CEA and MRP 2 standing confirmed what we
said earlier about the bio canaliculi
domains we saw in 2d are actually also
produced in 3d and interestingly we saw
over time that the proportion of CK 19
positive cells which are shown in the
upper right hand corner actually shifted
the numbers of a pata sites or the
proportions of a pata sites and Clady
sites their CK 19 is
marker for collegiate and liver and you
can see here they tend to form a sort of
exoskeleton around the sphere and we saw
this repeatedly and other labs have seen
this as well Magnussen Engelmann
sunbirds group showed this very nicely
in primary human dupatta sites that have
non-printable cells available in the
lower panel that you see here and so
it's it's encouraging that this this is
matching the types of responses and the
types of morphology that we see with
primary pata sites in the early days the
the spheroids are maturing that the the
CKD 19 positive staining tends to be a
little bit more distributed through the
sphere but over time it tends to be
highly localized on the periphery as you
see here so the hip arrrg are certainly
going through some adaptive response so
this image shows you the MRP two
staining in mr. chemistry staining
confocal imaging and you can see slices
through the spheres and this this
basically is confirming not only do
these high prodigy spheroids formed by
kind of lick a lot but the networks that
are formed are much more extensive than
what we saw in traditional 2d cultures
so it's very encouraging we're seeing
this this is definitely a good sign we
don't see any evidence of necrotic
centers forming and you can see the the
the Z sections as is scanning through
that you'll get these much more
extensive networks to be forming and so
this is evidence that the e flux
transport of the Billy reflux
transporter MRP to is localized and the
proper domains in these spheres moreover
when we look at coli cell fluorescein
which is a substrate for mr b2 and the
bile salt export pump we can see live
cell imaging that shows that dye is is
matching the types of internal networks
that we saw in the MRP to staining and
you can see also the very high levels of
Sat 3 for M&M reactive protein so we
started to figure to ask the question
well how do these spheres match with
other models in terms of the metabolic
complement spectrum that I mentioned
earlier and trying to achieve things in
the tux when
program and so I took so this is sort of
this is your life of metabolism as I've
gone to the different model systems and
cell types and you can see here the
median suspension of pata sites on the
far left of this plot sort of
representing the benchmark that's
approximating human liver again stalks
21 cell lines very low interestingly
these heifer are G cells even though
they're great cells if you culture them
in proliferating mode they actually
don't have metabolic competence that
that is even close to that the goal that
we're trying to achieve in suspensions
of a pata site and actually and priciple
on today's case at one a to the levels
are relatively comparable to help you to
cells but when you culture those cells
in a more differentiated State in 2d
differentiated State you can actually
see the activities increase about
tenfold and then when you culture them
in 3d spheroids you actually get very
close to the benchmark and these two
conditions are no DMSO on the far right
or 0.3% DMSO in the next motion and in
the p i-- t on the left side of that in
that box so what these data are telling
us is these little small spheres of
Hippo are g cells are able to achieve
sufficient levels of specific activity
that rivals the the activities observed
in primary hyuna pata sites now my first
concern was well if we've got very high
activities maybe we've just induced
these things by having them in 3d and I
was very happy to see that not only were
we able to achieve high basal levels but
we were also able to see further induce
ability of set 182 v6 in step 3 for mRNA
and enzymatic activity this case were
showing the mRNA with classical
activators of the aryl hydrocarbon
receptor the constitutive antigen
receptor and the pregnant x receptor and
so these are again hallmarks of a pata
site functionality and what they're
confirming to us is that not only as a
system basal metabolism very robust but
it's also analogous to the liver able to
functionally respond to classical
chapter pathways for the liver that
upregulate expression and enzymatic
activity of these pathways and so this
is this is what we want to model in
terms of liver so we're very excited
about these models and their ability to
to be able to as we say have our cake
and eat it to on the on the metabolism
and they're in the receptor signaling
pathways but there are lots of
challenges and we'll talk about those as
we go along one of the things in the in
the paper that we put published a couple
years ago is basically showing aflatoxin
b1 which is metabolically activated and
you can see here that compared to 2d
hyper G which is showing up in the the
right the the least potent curve across
this group as we switch to 3d steroids
we see a left shift and the potency they
become more sensitive which is
consistent with what we'd expect that
the the ic50 shifts from 46 micro molar
down to by 8 micro molar and then by
doing repeated exposure we shift that
even further to the right side doing
more damage and to get a sense of
whether this was related to metabolism
we use one amino benzoic hand panel and
you can see we were able to markedly
attenuate the cytotoxicity that was
observed with aflatoxin by doing that so
even just a simple cytotoxin when you
have this kind of metabolism could be a
very useful tool and we actually showed
that in the paper that included looking
at drug analogue case studies where the
one one drug analog in this case trove
ofloxacin
or tro glue to zone was withdrawn from
the market due to liver injury and what
we what we did was compare those liver
injury compounds with drug analogues
that weren't as as what warrant is often
associated or weren't associated all
with liver injury and what you see is
just using a simple cytotoxicity and
repeated exposure with the 3d spheroids
we were able to pick up these molecules
and and might have done a better job
with these kinds of data and flagging
this for additional focus before they
were released in the market so we think
this is a value
all tool to begin to to apply in various
drug and environmental chemical
estimations of liver injury not only do
we have the model for human primary
parasites in hippo G but we've also been
working with rata pata sites as I said
for the parallelogram approach industry
knees been doing a great job and and and
leading this effort you can see on the
lower left hand corner we get similar
types of staining to what we saw with
the the hippo AG spheres if you get this
pan cytokeratin sort of exoskeleton on
the outside of the sphere the metabolic
activities as we might expect are very
strong for the first 24 hours they drop
as the the spheroids adapt and recover
from this process and then out to 714
days they're perfectly happy we've gone
out to 28 days after this and we do see
a slight decrease is about 50% decrease
in the activities from from those levels
but we're still working on things like
cell culture media composition to see if
there are things that we're doing in 3d
spheroids that may be altering that but
we're very excited that for this 14-day
window the model would be quite useful
for us trini also confirmed that the
model is metabolically inducible so this
is treatment with phenobarbital and you
can see step 2 b1 mrna is is quite
nicely inducible again consistent with
the hipper G's and important for us in
the toxicology field and then liver
injury compound like diclofenac is able
to show a loss of viability as you get
to higher exposure levels and so we're
in the process of putting this system
through its paces with a battery of
chemicals and also with high-throughput
transcriptomics so the majority of the
presentation today I wanted to talk
about our efforts not only with these
model systems to try to tackle modeling
the liver in some sort of basic way that
that's useful but also to begin to
explore what are the features that are
distinguishing 3
dimensional cultures two-dimensional
cultures and proliferating cultures from
one another to be able to better
understand when to apply the various
models should different questions and so
to do that what we've done is chosen a
set of twenty-four compounds as our
reference set of chemicals to begin
looking at this and the majority of
these chemicals are shown in purple our
liver injury compounds or compounds that
have been associated with metabolically
activated liver injury the one shown in
Burgundy are hepatic receptor activators
and their classical inducers or
activators of the arrow hydrocarbon
receptor pregnant x receptor
constitutive antigen receptor farness
oeid x receptor FXR and the peroxisome
proliferator activated receptor alpha p
power alpha and so those are all shown
in Burgundy
we also a analogous to what I showed
earlier we have the four drug analogs
rosiglitazone versus true glitters own
and labor fluxes and vs. trove ofloxacin
and then finally a set of compounds that
have generally been shown to almost
never be associated with liver injury
including aspirin and caffeine and
sucrose so in terms of these chemicals
we ran a series of assays with this
study cell morphology using either an
inca site zoom or an image express
confocal molecular formula molecular
devices using cytotoxicity with LD h
leakage in each of the systems every
time we change culture media and then
high-throughput transcriptomics using a
novel platform that we have we have we
have worked with you know i'll describe
more about that in a moment we also
collected supernatant from the study for
metabolomic studies and some of those
studies are also being published but i
don't have time to talk about those
today so i want to go into this high
throughput transcriptomics a bit so one
of the challenges in our program is if
you try to do whole transcriptome or RNA
seek analysis on chemical screening it
would be an incredibly resource
intensive exercise and so the idea was
to try to focus
transcriptomics and genomics research
for toxicology applications and so led
by Rick Paulus and Scott Auerbach and
sheer Saudi pop Marv we've we've
developed a set of genes called the s
1500 plus gene set that is selected for
capturing diversity it's attempting to
find Sentinel genes that sort of
maximize our coverage of pathways and in
this case it started out as roughly
1,500 genes and then it got expanded
through nominations into about close to
3,000 transcripts or a twenty 977 and
then an ultimate goal was to see if you
could then take these data and be able
to extrapolate it out to what the whole
transcript would be and so this is
published in PLoS ONE you can take a
look at that the highlight would be that
we try to to cover all the biological
response pathways that were possible and
as efficient method as possible and
using the in cat's bio planet that's
recently been released to the public and
you can see that link below you you are
able to cover with four or more
transcripts seventy-seven percent of the
genes in in the human pathways
annotations ago biological process but
you at least have one or more genes and
96 percent of currently annotated human
pathways so this is a very very focused
but efficient way to cover biological
space and the platform is currently
offered commercially by a company called
bio spider and they've labeled the
platform tempo seek it is a modified
razzle seek and the set of twenty nine
hundred and seventy seven transcripts
are interrogated in our approach and we
what's really nice about the platform is
you can do direct lysis and assay you
don't have to do any RNA isolation which
is a massive hurdle when you're talking
about these kinds of studies and so we
see between one and twenty five thousand
cells for well depending on the assay
system we
lysis buffer to a total of 20
microliters and then we run the tempo
seek assay and in our shop that the
tempo seek assays we don't run it and
currently we're by spiders doing that
under under under work under contracts
with us but the assay works and it's
been published you can see Joey Cleese
paper from 2017 and plus one here the
assay works by targeting 50 mer oolagah
nucleotides that are spaced by a bridge
that is ligated that's the sort of
razzle the ligation part of this and
then essentially removing excess ala
goes and leveraging the the the detector
all ago ligation that happens you're
able to with barcoding on these ala goes
load all of the samples into a few lanes
of a next-gen sequencer and you're able
to get map sequences map recounts for
the targeted 50 mer region that you're
looking for for the 20 977 transcripts
that we look at it you can dig into more
the details there but suffice it to say
instead of sequencing everything you're
sequencing very targeted an efficient
set of alleles a set of regions of these
and so the idea is to understand the
relative expression of those map
recounts relative to one another and you
have to do that on a high seek and
currently that's done by spider for us
and then they send us fast queue files
we take those fast queue files and we've
developed a QC pipeline that looks at
sequencing depth alignment rates the per
base sequence quality pass/fail flags we
do account for cytotoxicity and and and
looking at the data and flagging it
we're looking at for the counts per
million and we do normalize the data
from each each well to a common accounts
per million target as the efficiencies
from well to well can vary we floor the
data that I'll be showing you today at a
recount of 5 and we we're
playing with different different floors
but right now we're somewhere between
five and ten we log to transform the
data and then our partners at SCI own
basically finished the QC pipeline by
giving us a series of output files that
are ready to import to be MD Express
partek flow and ingenuity pathway
analysis and we get out after the QC
pipeline these map recounts and here's
an example of the QC flags that Sam is
providing for us and you can see that
the concentrations that we added on
these plates were actually high on the
left-hand side starting in column three
and they went to lower concentrations as
you got to the right and so you can get
a sense of the types of data we're
getting and certainly when you have
cytotoxicity which is happening on the
left hand side of the plate you get a
lot more flags as you might expect as
activities and gene expression is
lowered so now I want to go into this
study in more detail and kind of some of
the things we saw when we leveraged this
high throughput transcriptomics platform
and as a person who's been working in
the liver enzyme induction world for the
majority of my career the first thing I
wanted to do with these data was to look
at reference Sentinel genes specific
transcripts that I'm very comfortable
with with liver models and understand do
they do they show the same types of
responses that you see with a
conventional TaqMan assay and what you
see here on the upper left is the
expression of SIP 1a1 that was in the s
1500 array and you can see in the black
curve is the hipper RG cells in
proliferated mode and they had a nice
response to the HR activator omeprazole
in 2d cultures you can see a mep result
but also in do produce an induction of
sip 181 but the basal levels for SEP 21
were much lower in 2d relative to
obliterated now this actually makes
perfect sense since we know that sip 1 a
1 is overexpressed in developing liver
and so this this actually makes perfect
sense and then looking at a different
facet of a Metra's old response we know
that omeprazole is metabolically
activated
bicep 3 a 4 to a sulfone metabolites
shown on the lower left in red in a
cartoon in that metabolite is thought to
be a agonist for the pregnant X receptor
and so that metabolically activated
response would then lead to a pxr
activation and induction of Sat 3 4 so
in the lower right hand corner if you
look at sip 3 for induction comparing
the proliferated versus a 2 dimensional
differentiated and hyper G you see that
the 2d differentiated had far superior
metabolic activity or sorry induction of
a sip 3 for mRNA by activation through
the presumed to be through activation of
the protein and x receptor compared to
the political cultures that had far far
lower constitutive levels of step 3 for
mRNA as well as smaller induce ability
and we saw that across the board when
you look at the the spectrum of pathways
that the sort of reference pathways for
a charc RPX are people are and FX are
you can see genes that are Sentinel to
those pathways generally produce a
larger dynamic range in the 2d
differentiated cultures and
interestingly also somewhat left shifted
potency so the the proliferating cells
tended to be a little bit more sensitive
and this could be related to in vitro
disposition and other factors that we
are as yet unclear on but what we do
know is that the 2d differentiated
models are working properly and these
data confirm that these pathways are
working analogous to the types of
studies we would run for liver enzyme
induction predictions for for regulatory
studies so the 3d cultures the first
batch that we ran actually failed and
we're not still not quite sure we
haven't been able to replicate the
failure but since that time we've done
lots more work with the 3d cultures and
you can see here very nice induce
ability of set 3/4 of to be 6 in
response to rifampicin and phenobarbital
and the 3d cultures looking at tempo
seek data and then doing ingenuity
pathway
sort of untargeted analysis karan pics
are pathways essentially populated at
the very top in response to these
activators and so this is very
encouraging that we're seeing the things
we're supposed to see an enriched way
now our program is moved towards not
only using these types of unsupervised
approaches and these individual genes
that are really reference genes or
Sentinel genes for a pathway but
starting to look at more of a global
pathway analysis and to do that
Scott Auerbach and our program L in
collaboration with acai ohm has
generated the next iteration of BMD
Express and this is beamed Express 2.0
this package is very effective and
efficient in taking various types of
data and doing dose response modeling
and what we've done after a workshop
that we had to try to understand the
best approaches for analyzing these data
is that we've actually leveraged the
power of concentration response modeling
to filter the data so we first run a
Williams trend test on the data to see
if we have a dose response curve and
then we filter that based on a fold
cutoff usually to fold or 1.5 fold and
then we do benchmark concentration
analysis and that's essentially for
those of you who aren't familiar with it
it's looking at the point of departure
so you have a curve and you have the
vehicle controls variation and then you
have a dose response trend and if it has
a dose response trend and there's a
statistically significant point of
departure that you define in the
software then we call that a benchmark
concentration curve or BMC if you're
doing in vivo would be a benchmark dose
of BMD which is where your software was
originally designed and so in our case
we're leveraging this the software to
basically identify dose response
relationships in the data and then
summarize that and what what is referred
to as accumulation plots so you can you
can consider this somewhat like a
concentration resolved histogram and so
on the upper left you see the response
for one gene that's a classical way of
looking at a dose
response relationship the point of
departure for that curve would then be
one of the circles on the accumulation
plot shown on the lower right hand side
and what we see when we start to look at
this dose response histogram is that
genes that are associated with the
pregnant x receptor those that painted
in red in this particular plot that I
did manually before we had the ability
to paint pathways are actually all
showing up on the left-hand side of the
of the dose response and it
concentrations that are below the
maximum therapeutic concentrations that
are known in humans under the classical
exposure levels meanwhile pathways
related to stress in ER stress oxidative
stress a pitocin set have historically
been associated with rifampicin
exposures as well they're all showing up
on the right-hand side of the curve so
you're starting to see this ability to
resolve sort of off target or
pharmacological pathways from things
that are happening at higher
concentrations it might be stress death
very deleterious pathways and so we
believe that the the concentration
response modeling and the filtering of
the data enables us to have this power
of resolution to start distinguishing
out the the sort of intended and
unintended effects of chemicals and
we've leveraged this across the full set
of 24 compounds and this is published in
our June paper and 2019 in talks I where
we took this set of 24 compounds and
essentially generated these benchmark
concentration and analyses and
accumulation plots for each of the
chemicals in the set and it was run
three independent times this is one of
the runs and what you see is compounds
like aflatoxin chlorpromazine drug
litters own acetaminophen drove
ofloxacin ritonavir benzo a pyrene all
the liver injury compounds are just
blowing up gene expression you see these
these sort of hockey stick type
appearances and this is in line with the
general thinking around genomics and
cellular stress and death response
what's nice about this system is it has
the resolution to not only tell you if
something could be liver injury compound
but we were able to use the data to
fine a threshold for liver injury
estimation and that as threshold was
three standard deviations above the mean
of the presumed rarely associated or
negative compounds that we published in
the paper and so what you end up seeing
is what the point at which the
accumulation plot crosses the threshold
is an estimation of the relative potency
of that molecule to cause liver injury
in humans and when you start to look at
where those concentrations are in
comparison with where liver injury is
observed you can calculate what I termed
a silly index or a chemical induced
liver injury index that's 10 times C max
divided by the threshold concentration
which is called BMC 105 in this case
because the 115 that was changed was
deemed the statistically driven
threshold for this data set now that'll
be a moving average as we add more
chemicals to this approach but it's an
untargeted way to rapidly screen and
understand if a chemical has liver
injury potential and at what
concentrations you might start to be
more concerned about that for follow-up
studies so we're really excited about
that in addition to the the potency
estimations you can also begin to
integrate other data types so in this
case we see morphology data that was
collected in the study and all these
data have been published and they're all
publicly available and you can go to the
publication and see those those links
but we host it here and a NASA database
called subs as well as the traditional
genomics databases as well but in this
case the images you can look at all the
images yourself this is an image on the
far left showing the proliferated versus
the 2d hyper RG and culture we use an
inky site zoom to get these images for
every single culture well at multiple
times throughout the exposure period and
you can see here highlighted or
hepatocyte sinkhole NGO sites in the in
the in the 2d you can't really
distinguish those cell types in the
proliferating mode very effectively but
for 96 hours you'll see that the 2d
cultures looked comparable whereas the
proliferating cultures you can clearly
see that they
liberated during the culture there in
the exposure period and become virtually
confluent after 96 hours now when we
treated with chemicals we saw many cases
where that wasn't affected at all and
then as you got to higher concentrations
you would often see cells die and you
would lose all the cells on the culture
what was interesting though is when you
start to look at some of the transition
zones like 1.5 micromolar aflatoxin we
actually saw areas where you saw
attenuation of proliferation because you
see less cells here so those cells were
dying or cells weren't growing as fast
which is consistent with what we know
about the mechanism of aflatoxin b1 but
moreover in the 2 t cultures you can
actually see evidence of scarring where
cells have died and the other cells are
and these are presumably claim G sites
that are trying to fill in the gaps and
trying to repair and do damage repair
and this is actually shows up in the
pathway analysis it also shows up in the
the LDH leakage data so you can see the
the sort of threshold that we're looking
at here 1.5 micro molar was right at the
edge where you started to have clear
cytotoxicity and again all these curves
are available as well for your evidence
for your for your further look but the
take-home is is that these these model
models as you start to integrate so
viability cell morphology and what I'm
going to show you next transcriptomics
you can begin to get a more
contextualized understanding of what's
happening in response to the chemical
exposure that not only informs you about
potencies that can also inform us about
what's going on and so in this case this
is pathway analysis using ingenuity
pathway analysis as well as benchmark
concentration modeling on the upper
right hand corner that reveals the types
of pathways we would expect to see with
aflatoxin a pitocin p53 signaling DNA
damage cell cycle and comparing to D
versus proliferated we saw that the the
relative trends we would have expected
to see with those molecules both in
terms of aflatoxin as well as another
genotoxic agent benzo a pyrene
which is also metabolically activated
and the sort of take-home from all of
this is we're starting to build
relationships now between genomic or
transcriptomic pathways and phenotypic
changes that are happening in the cell
cultures to build confidence about those
relationships and our ability to
interpret the genomic data now one of
the really cool compounds that we took a
look at and then one of the most
difficult to model in vitro with less
metabolically competent systems to
cyclophosphamide
and this just captures a high-level
summary of that but when we cultured the
cells in proliferated mode we saw
virtually nothing which is consistent
with the fact that cyclophosphamide
requires SIPTU v6 activation to form the
ultimate cytotoxic phosphor i'd mustard
in acryl and that are a bit more
stressful in 2d cultures in the
publication that we showed originally we
got decent modeling and you can see we
have some response here that's starting
to show pathways that actually made
sense but when we were able to generate
the 3d data relatively recently and
these data are still unpublished we saw
a massive increase in the amount of
transcripts that were observed and when
we looked at the pathways there they
make sense lipid hydroxylation p450
metabolism and as you go to higher
concentrations you get into cell cycle
oxidative stress DNA damage hypoxia
which is actually observed in elderly
patients who are exposed to
cyclophosphamide in many cases and and
and start to have issues in maintaining
the oxygen levels in their blood so you
know we're starting to leverage this
information further we need more work to
understand it better but the 3d model
seems to really be doing some some very
special things in a metabolically
dependent state that we want to test
further at inhibitors and and do
follow-up so in the publication in talks
on 2019 we actually also looked at the
trove of flock system versus label
fluxes in comparison and you can see
readily the massive distinction between
label fluxes and even though it had
higher therapeutic exposure levels
versus trova foxes and both of these
molecules were designed to to be used in
therapeutic treatment of pneumonia and
so you would imagine most of the effects
you would
would hope to see very little effects on
human liver and in fact we saw a pretty
massive response with trove of foxes and
that would have given us pause to move
that molecule forward and and similarly
if you look at the pathway level instead
of the gene level you get lots of
pathways related to cell killing a
Potosi DNA damage you really see none of
that with it leyva fox isn't using the
same filters so all in all very
promising and the fact that we can begin
to distinguish clinically relevant drug
analogues that have been used and have
different outcomes in humans it gives us
more confidence that we're headed down
the right path now a couple another case
study that i want to talk about is
triplet his own versus rosiglitazone so
the transcriptomic pathway analysis was
able to readily differentiate these
molecules analogous to the trova foxes
versus Leiva Fluxus an analysis that we
did earlier and you see the cell that
self stress and damaged pathways painted
here where rosy glitter zone is far less
potent than intro glitter zone which is
shown in the three independent runs on
the on the left left set of curves that
are sort of sloping interestingly this
is one of the few molecules we had in
the set where we actually had the
ability to start looking at therapeutic
target interactions and when we did that
for P power gamma in the case of these
glitter zone molecules we saw a very
puzzling relative potency so tro
glitters own which would be on the left
hand set of curves that showed people
are gamma potencies that were far more
potent than pathways that were
identified in response to rosiglitazone
now that's completely reversed from what
we know in people our game a reporter
gene assays where trigger to zone is in
fact about 515 animal or potency versus
a teen animal with rosiglitazone and
this was quite puzzling at first for me
but one of the things that we can do and
BM to express is start to look under
these data and start to say well what
what genes are making up these pathways
and how are they responding individually
and so you can do these curve overlays
in the package and it was readily
obvious that if you look at highly
specific
selective compounds us our genes that
are in the people are game a pathway
like adiponectin and fatty acid binding
protein for the relative potencies
between rosiglitazone and triplet is
only matched perfectly what's happened
is it likely due to the lack of ability
to resolve self stress and damaged
pathways versus more closely focused
therapeutic targets you're actually
getting the median BMD which is plotted
on that that original plot is being
pulled by the transcripts that are
basically producing responses at the
very very highest concentrations and so
that median is being shifted due to what
is likely a confounding effect on
cellular stress pathways it's possible
that also currently annotated pathways
aren't universally applicable to adipose
verses liver and we need more work to
try to understand that but the general
presumption in the field is is if it's a
pathway it's always a pathway across all
so the the the pathways that are
currently annotated may not be
universally applicable to all cell types
and cell contexts another example that
we've just generated and really exciting
data that we need to repeat multiple
times to make sure but one of the big
failures in the 2d versus proliferate
study that's been published was valproic
acid we presumed that because we did not
achieve levels that were 10 times c max
at our highest concentration that we
likely just just didn't go high enough
in exposure and that may be true but
when we did the 3d hypo G with the
valproic acid and looked at those same
concentration ranges it was a massive
increase in in pathways this molecule is
metabolically activated and what we saw
was low concentration effects on fatty
acid biosynthesis and mitochondrial
fatty acid beta oxidation that are
consistent with what we know are effects
with valproic acid on lipid levels and
lipid homeostasis
we actually saw an interesting effect on
the GABA receptor pathway which normally
you don't think about and liver
it looks like we were able to clearly
identify that and we need to do this
multiple iterations but it's possible
that even though we're in liver we may
be able to pick up effects that would be
predictive of therapeutic effects and
other tissues and then as you get to
higher concentrations we know that
idiosyncratic liver injury and hyper
ammonia anemia or observed like that's
been associated with mitochondrial
toxicity and as you get to the very
highest levels you can see urea cycle
cell cycle mitotic effects that are
popping up and so this is very
encouraging we're really excited about
it and we're hopeful that this is gonna
be much more powerful as we go to the
full set of 24 compounds in the next
couple of months another example
rifampicin comparing 2d vs. 3d we see
that both models are able to model car
and pxr signaling you can see and we
also get higher exposure level people
are signaling and 2d you see the same
pathways in 3d that are lighting up so
the 2d models working but what we think
may be happening and you can see it
manifests in additional pathways are
lighting up in 3d that they may be
modeling a more comprehensive set of
biological responses and we're not sure
it's possible that this is more related
to in vitro disposition differences
between 3d and 2d we've had projects
that are starting to dig into that that
question and understand it
but when we took the data in Street took
the IPA analysis and compared the benzo
a pyrene pathways p53 HR signaling fatty
fibrosis lots of different pathways and
you look at that 3 micro molar exposure
in 3d versus 2d vs. proliferated in the
3 columns and what you see is that we
have a clear enrichment of genes within
a pathway in 3d relative to the 2d and
proliferated mode so it's quite possible
that 3d are just better mimicking the
pathways that have been historically
annotated in vivo and from other data
sources to give a more comprehensive
sort of modeling and capturing of the
dynamics
going on in the system now he also is
happy to point out that the pancreatic
adenocarcinoma is identified as one of
the pathways here and that has been
associated with benzo a pyrene in in in
humans so point that out now while we we
have a lot of opportunities with the 3d
I've tried to capture some of those
long-term culture ability ability to to
model more complex metabolic activated
responses more efficient use of cells
there are lots of challenges we've had
recent issues with plate manufacturing
that we're not able to always get the
plates that are working for us changing
the culture media can be a challenge if
you don't have the right pipette systems
in place we're still trying to
understand the unique properties of 3d
so it culture media has been evolved
from 2d cultures that generally are not
have not been optimized in tuned for 3d
cultures and we're starting to see some
differences that may suggest that there
are some some needs to go and to look
deeper and we're starting to look at
that now to see if there's some things
some of the factors include DMSO
hydrocortisone insulin glucose and then
probably the biggest issue with these
particular models as you're dealing with
a very small number of cells for well so
trying to scale the biomass of that
small amount of cells per the media
volume into quantitative translation to
humans needs calibration and so we're
gonna need work to maybe titrate the
numbers of spheres and things like that
to better mimic or to come up with
informatics ways to adjust the data
depending on the data stream that were
able to achieve now one of the things
Caitlin leverage is a new postdoc in the
group and one of the things she did was
start to culture these things out for
very long periods of time and she saw
very disturbing but maybe exciting
opportunity with HIPAA prodigy cells and
that was when you culture them with no
DMSO 0% for 56 days you actually saw
they more than doubled in size and
density and I'll show you that the plot
and she uses ear 0.3% day
I said she actually saw that that effect
went away so you can see the density
shift is much much more attenuated now
these hep RG cells were derived from a
pod a cellular carcinoma so it's
possible that they have some cancer
properties that are manifesting in these
systems over time we know they do not
grow in nude mice it's been published
we've we've heard that they will grow
somewhat in soft order so that what we
presume that was more of a stem cell
property but at this time it may be an
opportunity to start to look at
molecules that could disrupt this effect
and maybe start infer some ability of
molecules to to interact we know that
the MSO has been associated with a p1
signaling and so that tumor suppressor
type pathway might be operative here
we're definitely going to dig into that
more and kaylynn's been not only looking
at that but looking at the baseline
genomics between our systems and also
the bioenergetics between the systems to
try to understand what is really unique
between 3d and 2d systems of what she's
finding in the gene expression is that
the 3d are enriched and things we've
been talking about zina body metabolism
bile acid metabolism but they're also up
regulated in oxidative phosphorylation
meanwhile 2d cultures seem to be
enriched in epithelial mesenchymal
transition so evidence of back
differentiation hypoxia inflammatory
response and glycolysis which is
intriguing and that may be 3d cultures
might actually be more aerobic while 2d
cultures more anaerobic and more work is
needed on that but preliminary data from
SOT suggested that the oxygen
consumption rate and spheroids of
primary human pacifies was far greater
in 3d than it was in 2d so more work to
be done there but if energy is being
used different in these systems cultural
media may need to be optimized as well
so in summary I hope I've conveyed to
you some evolving approaches that we're
using here in natasha 21 program to
improve the physiological relevance and
the ability to model xena baudet
metabolism and to begin to bring online
assays that don't just cover one path
at a time but cover a broader spectrum
of pathways and we're hopeful that
future models are going to allow us to
expand this concept out to a broader set
of toxicological tools and do approach
methods I hope I've convinced you the
high throughput transcriptomics with
this platform can be a very efficient
survey of responses and allow you to to
rapidly gain an understanding of posey
and potential for liver injury and then
to begin to look under the hood to
understand what may be happening in an
in a manner that leverages the resolving
power of concentration response modeling
to distinguish the effects of lower dose
exposures that may be more
pharmacological versus the off-target
and higher exposure levels that may be
starting to get to cell stress and death
and understanding the context of where
you are in that system and then finally
an upcoming focus on maturation kinetics
and time response and reversibility is
currently going on in the lab without I
do I do want to highlight I know i
highlighted Trini Rama Gauri and Caitlin
leverage for their work Scott Auerbach
as well in his pioneering work with the
BM to express 2.0 Rik Paulus and his
efforts with Shyam and Scott and mushiya
Shah and Deepak Mata to get us the the s
1500 array Mike DeVito who's our branch
chief and the NTP labs and all of our
colleagues there who are working
diligently on the various model systems
to try to develop better methods and
understand chemicals that were being
exposed to as well as Alex Merrick and
Nisha sipes and their work três três
Adler as well who helped a lot with the
transcriptomics and I always want to
mention it lick loose who taught me
everything I know about primary liver
cells and with that I'd be happy to take
any questions